have people around you who inspire you
who lift you up who show you that it's
possible I love my YouTube channel for
myself I need it for me I surround
myself with Steve Jobs and Kanye and
Oprah and all these people for me for
myself I want it I want to be around
successful people because what it does
it rubs off on you it's like they're
sprinkling little Steve Jobs pixie dust
on you it rubs off it shows you two
things one that it's possible because
all of your Heroes they started with
less than what you currently have right
now you feel like it's overwhelming and
impossible in your environment and it's
just it's never going to happen whoever
you look up to whoever your heroes are
they had it worse than you have it right
now they struggle through worse than
what you're struggling through right now
and so if they could do it you can't Doo
there's no excuse